let's look at these two blocks here
block one has a mass of 3m and block two
has the mass of one M and they are
colliding and sticking together and then
they're going to move in this direction
and eventually slide onto this rough
surface here what we want to figure out
is what was that initial velocity V
naught with which the two blocks
collided so up to this part here in
before this x equals zero there is no
external force acting on the system so
conservation of momentum holds which
means that P final equals P initial okay
so let's put this together we're going
to have three m v-not that block goes in
the positive I hat direction block two
goes the opposite way so we have M V
naught and then at the end when they're
stuck together before here we have to
consider only this portion here with
that pertains to a frictionless surface
we have four M V final and so the ends
fall out this is 2 this is 4 so we'll
see that what the final velocity is V
naught 1/2 now in order to get to this V
naught we also have to consider energy
and in particular we have to use the
work-energy principle here because this
this joint block is going to slide onto
this rough surface here so we can make
use of the work-energy principle is we
know what the initial conditions are up
to this or at this point here using the
conservation of momentum from here in
the first place so we want to use work
equals Delta K the work energy principle
let's look at the work first work is the
integral of F dot d s
and while dealing with a one-dimensional
problem here so we can just write FX DX
and we want to have this run from zero
to D I should say here that this block
eventually comes to rest at x equals D
we're going to use that in a second so
let's look at what this F is that's the
frictional force here at work and
actually which direction does it go it
opposes the motion FK so we're going to
get a minus sign here integral FK DX
again going from X prime equals zero to
X prime equals D now what is this f K we
know that FK equals mu K N and from
doing a quick free body diagram we'll
see that we have four mg going down and
we have a normal force going up and so
we'll see that N equals four mg which we
can then plug in here and then that goes
in over there and the coefficient of
kinetic friction is actually given to us
so that nicely works out so we're gonna
have minus integral x prime 0 X prime
equals D the coefficient first be x
squared and then the N for mg D X if we
integrate that we're going to get minus
4 B mg and we'll integrate this one so
that's an X cubed over 3 and we're going
to plug in this value here so we're
going to get a D and that second term
falls away
so we left with a D cubed here so this
is our work and now we need to look at
the change in kinetic energy between
here and there we already know that it
this block is at rest at x equals D so
if the velocity is zero our kinetic
energy will be zero and so our K final
minus K initial is going to be just a
minus initial
and that's initial here which is the
final situation of our collision so
we're going to look at the combined
block so we'll have minus one-half and
we have four M V final squared we
determined here already that the final
velocity is the initial one-half so
we'll have minus here we're going to
have two and V naught squared over four
and that actually gives us minus
one-half V naught squared
okay so now we can put this all together
we apply this work-energy principle so
we're going to get minus four-third the
mg the cubed equals minus 1/2 MV naught
squared we'll see that this and this and
this and this goes and so we're going to
get V naught equals 8/3 and then we have
B G d cubed and the square root of that
so this is our initial velocity with
which the two blocks collided initially
then eventually went onto this rough
surface and came to rest here at x
equals D